oh my goodness that's the spirit is so
cold noise all right there from a pro
Nadine oh wow
I've never had a slumber party inside a
tent before right now we are at the Cruz
Airport goodness it'll look like a
winner for you ah we're about to chicken
I brought a stapler just for the dice
Isaac tell me the difference between a
ninja dab and a regular dab what's that
[Music]
it's my poo fro all your blood
he's blocks down
[Music]
you're so lucky we're going on a cruise
so we're going to Santa Barbara and then
we're going to
- empanadas
it smells like everyone forgot to put
their laundry in the dryer take a wet
Airport smell but you've been on a
cruise before head until now I feel like
I'm coming home
I know I remember I got fat paid a whole
bunch of food and absolutely nothing but
sit around however you plan on doing it
and secret active overdoing this timer
huh
watch out
I'm also really happy because we get to
be still kind of go all of my closest
friends for my birthday because my
birthday is in a couple days one bigger
the important it is I'm even those as a
JK trip in my head it's like my birthday
we're on the crew day and give your
pictures wink and I take pictures then
so the voting tsa people give me crap
for videotaping it's still not
videotaping I give me okay we are on
board to go to the top
[Music]
we're 248 to break ever always overhead
it's kind of fancy but it's like the
airplane at all it is just like an
airplane
oh how cool you like have a grown closet
oh there's a microwave no cute Isaac
leave the microbe is a microwave oh my
girl ice check is in case of an
emergency
Oh bunk bed don't let it fall on you and
to do know who I want to sleep up here
yeah I'm excited to sleep here right oh
oh going up to your cruise bed Wow we
have the bottom view oh that means we're
gonna have the water we're gonna see the
ocean we have front-row seats for the
ocean ha ha third-class for the win we
get front-row seats for the water people
upstairs can't say that all right we are
in our room Isaac are you excited for
this I mean extremely side exit you are
the luckiest kid ever man thank you
you better appreciate your life you
better be happy with your life I'm
better be the most obvious person in the
world oh we should watch echo your kids
please oh yeah the kids on we're going
on a cruise
this morning when I told you that you
could walk around without your parents
here you kind of got freaked out a
little bit yeah you look like you were
freaking out but then we told you all
but it's really safe on the cruise
though how do you feel about your
freedom it kind of feels [ __ ] my
heart like feels like oh I'm like a doll
but literally younger I'll see you next
one all right bye yeah come on fun in
there
I want a kid's own fish am an adult zone
dude it's called a bar yeah I go inside
I feel like a Nickelodeon set right now
it does feel like a Nickelodeon TV show
set oh my goodness I have a flat here
alright so we're going to test Isaac's
navigation skills and since he is going
to be a grown-up on this cruise we're
gonna test the skills to see who can
take us back to our room from his kid
club pain all the way back to her room
is the ultimate test
you ready got it oh dear miss you he's
going to I don't want to go I don't
already go right here and you will
follow you
no have you not find food on a cruise is
almost an impossible thing to play
though so it's big
there's a big potential to get lost very
true we're going back to America we'll
find you
we're not lost at Isaac st. good so far
yeah you're tracing my steps for taking
my pass this test just yet cragger
lumetri now
[Music]
remember oh you're so close I know
you're getting warmer warmer colder
colder colder colder colder warmer
warmer warmer warmer Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing
Frankie see oh we got open it you must
have familiarize himself he wants to
like make sure he knows his corner nice
you passed the test
good job for sending 100% yeah it's a
pass/fail crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we were eating right now we're just
eating like nonchalantly and then we
realize everyone's gone it's like a go
ship and we're like wait where's
everybody where everybody go and then
the one of the guys tells us like oh
we're supposed to be doing this
emergency
Thanks jacket clothing a head cover any
medication that you know to use and
carrying the life-changing Dostum a
sensation ready for emergency we know
exactly how to do this again but with
all the added stressors of an emergency
yeah but yeah yeah yeah now it's back to
the program yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
I think rebooted where we going where's
our first stop by say 10 bourbon sambar
[Music]
[Music]
we're so beautiful
all right so it is orientation night
here on the cruise for the kids own
where I spend a little bit of time
playing air hockey Isaac at her I'm
always aggressive Oh skills
[Music]
this is mance to be a kid's own tip
night or hoping take it over
[Music]
[Music]
you'll have fun playing stuff at the
kids place and crashing a party I'd be
wary and I had way more fun that night
[Music]
[Music]
the night is coming to an end I think
this first day is in pretty dope it's
been really really eye-opening
experience I would say I think it's
really beautiful seeing Isaac explore
I'd like to experience something so new
and it's not only that but it's like
extra special because then I'm
experiencing something brand-new with
him as well so I think it's a really
beautiful experience is the second year
that you get to join us for our Jake a
film company trip it's really nice I'm
really thankful that JK considers him a
part of the crew as well as him join us
our trips
[Music]
son
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
today is day two of our cruise
adventures for Santa Barbara yelped it
in life is really good
[Music]